- Elle a 44 ans, elle mère
de deux enfants, réalisatrice
et interprète pour la télévision
d'État, la iiière chaîne en
Russie. Nos caméras ont pu la
suivre à sa sortie du tribunal,
à Moscou, où elle est revenue
àa a a charge encore une fois
contre le gouvernement
de Vladimir Poutine.
"C'était ma décision de
dénoncer la guerre, mon
initiative à moi", dit Marina
Ovsyvavavava, qui, avant-hier,
était une simple employée sans
histoire. Aujourd'hui, on
la décrit comme une des femmes
les plus courageuses de Russie.
Sa page Facebook est inondée
de messages qui saluent
sa bravoure. Celle qu'elle
amanifestée hier soir, quand
elle a fait irruption et c
"Non à la guerre" en direct,
sur le plateau du bulletin de
nouvelles le plus écouté au
pays. On peut lire sur l'affiche
qu'elle a brandi
"Ne croyez pas la propagande.
On vous ment."
Cinq petites secondes qui ont
fait le tour du monde,  alors
qu'elle était arrêtée et
détenue.
Elle dit avoir été libérée
parce qu'elle a des enfants,
mais dit avoir été interrogée
pendant plus de 14 heures
pendant lesquelles personne ne
savait où elle était. Plusieurs
chefs d'État, y compris Emmanuel
Macron, lui ont offert l'asile
et la protection, si nécessaire.
EMMANUEL MACRON
président de la France
- Je souhaite, en tout cas,
qu'au plus vite, nous puissions
avoir toute clarté sur sa
situation personnelle.
- Car elle est vraisemblablement
exposée à une peine
de prison qui pourrait aller
jusqu'à 15 ans, et ce en vertu
de la nouvelle lrererererend
illégale toute action publique
qui discrédite l'armée russe.
La loi sur la censure
est tellement sévère qu'elle
a poussé des dizaines de
journalistes internationaux,
mais surtout russes
indépendants, à l'extérieur du
pays qui sont venus s'installer
ici, à Riga, en Lettonie,
parce que c'est la seule façon
de rapporter les faits sans
la crainte de subir
des représailles.
Katrina Abramova travaille pour
le journal indépendant Meduza,
qui a installé ses journalistes
à Riga pour des raisons de
sécurité. Elle n'en revient pas
du geste posé en direct par
sa consoeur.
Et que dire de ce manifeste
que Marina Ovsyannikova a publié
pour expliquer la honte qu'elle
Et que dire de ce manifeste
que Marina Ovsyannikova a publ
pour expliquer la honte qu'elle
éprouve d'avoir menti aux Russes
et de les avoir réduit à l'état
de zombie avec la propag
Ce qui se passe actuellement
en Ukraine est un crime.
Toute la responsab
de cette agression repose sur
la conscience d'un seul homme :
Vladimir Poulelelelelelele.
Elle a aussi invité les Russes
à manifester, ce qui lui a valu
une amende de 350 $.
Parmi les messages
d'enquququququququ'elle a reçu,
il y a celui-ci,
du président de l'Ukraine,
Volodymyr Zelensky.
"Merci aux Russes", dit-il,
qui font sortir la vérité, qui
luttent contre la désinformation
comme l'ememememememememme avec
sa pancarte."
Ce qui attend Marina n'est pas
encore c'a'a'a'a'a'a'a'a pas été
testée. Est-ce ce que
le gouvernement russe voudra
qu'on l'oublie? Ou est-ce qu'on
fera d'elle un exemple du prix à
umumumumumumumumilier le Kremlin
et son armée?
Ici Tamara Alteresco,
Radio-Canada, à Rig